on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and sends to one
year on from a late Queen's death are
the Royals in Iraq and our Prince
Harry's Relentless attacks to blame for
that that rock we'll debate that
a terror suspect flees jail by clinging
to the underside of a van dressed as a
chef how the hell did this happen
fast why is President Biden plunging in
popularity with black voters Charlemagne
the God one of the most interesting
characters in American Media and most
influential or join me live
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening London welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored a year ago tomorrow Britain
changed irrevocably it was a day that I
and many others have waited for and
frankly dreaded for my entire adult life
the late Queen was 96 when she died of
failing health I mean the subject of
speculation of course for months and
we'd all watched her becoming steadily
older and more frail for several years
but part of her magic was that aura of
invincibility she was the ever-present
comfort blanket as much a fact of life
as the changing of our Seasons we all
knew that one day that awful day would
come and we all knew that we would miss
the queen enormously we all knew that
things were going to have to change
anything I got wrong is exactly how much
I think we miss her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II a monarchy didn't just lose
its figurehead also much of a sparkle
the magic
since she died Britain seems at the same
time to have completely lost a plot
we've smashed into crisis of the crisis
like a broken shopping trolley the late
Queen represented us to the world with
Grace and dignity and humility and hard
work
and she was acclaimed around the world
for those values and virtues charlatans
like Boris Johnson and Liz truss made us
a laughing stop by comparison as I keep
saying it just feels like nothing really
works anymore schools fall into pieces a
terror suspect escaping from jail air
traffic shut down by a dodgy line of
code a broken NHS Health Service endless
strikes violent crime soaring raging
inflation still causing huge cost of
living problems for millions of people
now sadly for our politicians it's not
possible to blame all of that on the
Queen's death much as they'd probably
like to try but it certainly compounded
the sense of listless chaos that's
dragging the country down that's exactly
why a strong monarchy with this
patriotic Pomp and ceremony is so
important of a national psyche The
Royals are the great symbolic
figureheads of our nation I believe we
need them swaggering and sparkling not
bickering and curdling if the Royals are
in a rut what's up so the rest of us got
the ghastly timing Prince Harry's back
in Britain tonight he's just been
speaking an award ceremony
as you know I was unable to attend the
awards last year as my grandmother
passed away
as you also probably know she would have
been the first person to insist that I
still come to be with you all instead of
going to her and that's precisely why I
know exactly one year on that she is
looking down on all of us tonight happy
we're together continuing to Spotlight
such an incredible Community well what
she wouldn't be happy about is he's not
together with any of his family he's
flown 6 000 miles from Los Angeles from
this luxurious world he now exists in
with his wife Megan fleecing their Royal
titles for gazillions of dollars but in
the process he's falling out with all
his family there are no plans we're told
then to meet his father King Charles or
his brother Prince William think about
that that's his father and his brother
and there were no plans when he's in the
city they live in to see them instead
he's going to award ceremonies
there's no chance it seems if any
Bridges being repaired and why should
there be how can you blame Charles and
William they've had to endure now years
of Relentless mutt-raking trash talk
from Harry and Megan which has done more
to tarnish the monarchy than anything I
can remember
this is just another stop on his endless
tour of well it's self-service isn't it
it's the worldwide privacy tool people
who wanted privacy but don't want
privacy they actually just want to be
seen as Kinder Royals without any of the
duty that goes with that and to get all
the benefits of that over in America
where they can make huge amounts of
money it's all about serving themselves
not the country here not duty to the
people of this country who bestowed of
course through the monarchy these titles
that they have
in that sense that everything that the
queen wasn't
and when he talks about unity and coming
together
there'll be people in the Palaces in
London tonight his family
open-mouthed saying really
you are preaching about unity and coming
together
every time Harry and Megan smear their
family in public for money it chips away
again at the Majesty of the monarchy it
reduces our greatest institution to this
reality show garbage the impact on the
monarchy is there for all to see and
it's got to stop
Harry needs to realize he's wrecking
something that's much much bigger than
him and his wife and their American
Media career and it's much more valuable
than their fragile hypocritical egos
well joining me now is author and
historian Tessa Dunlop by the author of
The Palace papers Tina Brown in America
by Royal historian author of the new
book after Elizabeth can the monarchy
save itself welcome to all three of you
team let me start with you
very much the queen of Royal experts in
my opinion so what is the queen of Royal
experts view as we incredibly it's a
year tomorrow I can remember every
moment of that day but it's a year
tomorrow that we lost uh Elizabeth II I
do I do feel a lot of the magic died
with the queen of the monarchy what do
they do about this
well you know I actually think that
Charles has actually gripped it in a way
that's very surprising actually I I
wouldn't really agree that it's all gone
away and all drained away I think that
in a strange way the chaos that you
vividly describe at the top of the show
has actually made Charles look a lot
better he's suddenly the great Statesman
on the world stage he's the most August
Statesman that England can really put
out there he's become a huge National
Asset and he really hasn't put a foot
wrong in the last year I agree that has
actually I think sort of surprised
everybody so that's good and you've got
the sparkle coming out of Kate and
William so I think that's not a bad
double Act of of Charles being the kind
of August grandfather of the country and
Sparkle Sparkle from William and Kate
here's the problem I don't think it's
quite as dire well he is why I think it
may be a little more diet than you think
and maybe not as dire as the picture I
painted I'm certainly a massive fan of
King Charles and queen Camilla I think
they're fantastic and done a great job I
think stabilizing things after what was
a very unstable period but young people
people in particular according to all
the polls at the moment 37 of 18 to 24
year olds want the monarchy to continue
40 on elected head of state only 30
percent think the royal family is good
value for money these are worrying
numbers for the Royals and it seems to
me that when I talk to young people they
all had great reverence and I think
interest in the queen but they're not so
reverential or interested in the others
at the moment it's not irretrievable but
at the moment I think there's a kind of
malaise
well you know I have to say that if
you'd ask people young people in the
1960s if they had a great reference for
the queen they would have absolutely
thought she was a complete boar you know
I mean when you had all of the Reverend
shows like that was the week that was
that was a period where the queen was
very much out of fashion she was
considered irrelevant
I don't think that if you had polling at
that time with all the young people at
that moment they would have particularly
thought the queen was this fabulous icon
that she became in a strange way the
last 20 years of the Queen's life sort
of was the most iconic time for her I
would actually argue that uh Stephen
frizz filmed the queen where with Helen
Mirren was a beginning of a kind of Pop
Culture Embrace of the queen where she
went from being someone irrelevant to
young people to suddenly being almost
like a sort of hip pop culture icon and
you had the thing with the uh her
wonderful appearance of the Olympics and
you had then she was packed with
Paddington Bear and all of a sudden the
queen was kind of co-opted by by pop
culture and she in her brilliant way
embraced it but I'm not sure that you
would have found young people thinking
she was so fabulous when she was in her
interesting point all right Tessa you've
been gagging to get in here as always
um I mean I I think there are a lot of
distractions going on at the moment
you've got the Harry and Megan thing
you've got the prince Andrew Scandal
still bubbling away we're apparently to
see the files on him now for some huge
amount of time for reasons that
completely baffle me
um you've got
problems I think for Charles and what
kind of monarchy he wants to present to
the world what's he going to change and
you've got William and Kate who I think
are doing a great job
um but come on the numbers when you
agreed with me that there was a ball
drop around the Women's World Cup that
was a mistake a clear way he could have
got some Headway with young people
William
I've made it very clear Williams should
have got on the first plane out to that
World Cup final and watched the
lionesses that he's a president of the
fa for goodness sake it was ridiculous
but actually that spoke to a deeper
stubbornness and dare I say entitlement
and you put once again if I may you put
all the blame on little pretty
Irrelevant in some respects Harry when
if what about all the blame on him
at the top and I took notes on it I put
a lot of extensive I put a lot of blame
on those a lot of blame because they're
the only the only two members of the
royal family who have done what they've
been I'm sure Ed your academic will
agree with me that the the broad
shoulders it should be anyway the broad
shows at institutional monarchy that has
to be where change comes from whether it
is the Redemptive Olive Branch offered
to Harry it needs to come from his
father from his brother who are part of
an institution of State not from a
prince who wears a beanie and goes
around you know Europe doing a
well-meaning charity gigs no it needs to
come from the the institution of
monarchy and actually deeper change you
mentioned their transparency access to
files Freedom of Information that needs
to come from the monarchy they need to
lead you're right call out the politics
politicians they're rotten we need to
see leadership from Charles Ed you wrote
a piece about all this uh pretty much
affirming uh that there is a rut in the
royal family like I said I think it's
irretrievable but I do sense it I do
sense there's been a kind of down
downturn if you like but we've been
through these before and they've bounced
back but what where do you think we are
with the royal family and the
institution of the monarchy and do you
see a way that they can get things back
on track
well actually uh peers I think you're I
think you're right there is something of
a rut here and I I have to briefly and
respectfully take issue with something
that Tina said before the opinion polls
in the 1960s that were taken there
weren't many of them but many young
people were asked more than 60 said that
the the queen represented The Best of
British uh and I think that was really
significant you know we've only got to
go back 10 years to 2013 and 72 percent
of young people were saying uh that the
monarchy would continue that they
supported it and that it was here to
stay
fast forward 10 years and things have
definitely changed and I think uh the
news and hubbub around Andrew and more
recently uh Harry and Megan are partly
to do with it but I think there's
something bigger here as well I think
there is a significant generational
divide over the monarchy just as there
is a significant significant General
divide in society more generally
regarding the state of the nation young
people under 45s especially and most
acutely the under 25s are totally
disenchanted with the state of modern
Britain and I think the monarchy as a
symbol at the heart of the country is
taking a lot of flack yeah I think
that's right Tina
Harry and Megan I don't particularly
like talking about them anymore I think
it's become a it's just a Relentless
kind of Groundhog Day thing really they
want attention they want to make money
out of the royal titles every time they
rear their heads to do it everyone I
hear goes nuts including me and then we
carry on repeat cycle
um what is going on with them in America
though I mean what is their reputation
like there now how relevant are they
we're hearing that Megan's planning her
big comeback
etc etc but where are they over there
okay well first of all just to say uh to
Tessa's point I completely agree about
William blowing it with the lionesses
but that's where I missed Harry actually
that's where they missed Harry sure
because you know if Harry had been part
of the mix you know Harry could have
gone to the lionesses wouldn't he have
been fabulous let's face it whatever you
think okay I would say I would say to
that why didn't he
that would have been really cool sorry
nothing nothing was stopping him getting
on a plane if he wanted to and he didn't
so he could have done but he wasn't the
presence
Williams should have gone as president
of the fa that was his duty to do that
and it was a very rare very bad misstep
by him to not do that and also actually
if you're a woman player for the England
team I mean how fast would you have got
on a plane have that been the England
men's team in the World Cup final he'd
have been like a greyhound on speed so I
but but Harry could have gone if he
wanted to he did anyway back back to the
bigger picture Harry and Megan in
America it's this brand
well I tell you what is interesting is
the fact that Megan's old show 12 years
old suits is actually the number one
show at the moment in America nobody
understands why somebody posted a meme
on Tick Tock and the whole thing
exploded it and suddenly suits this old
show is the third is the best viewed
Show on Netflix worldwide go figure
nobody knows and it's not really thought
is there anything to do with Megan but
it is an interesting thing well it's
actually a very I gotta say it's a very
good show I really liked suits yeah so
it doesn't surprise me I thought it was
great but why it's suddenly been dug out
of the sort of I know it's weird no but
it's not weird it is it's because
they've got the X Factor which is why we
find it painful when they left it was so
painful well it made as a Tina said it's
not necessarily because of Meghan Markle
but let me continue to The Wider point
about how popular they are what do you
think the The Wider point is well just
to say though that in that instance uh
Hollywood agents I speak to kind of say
actually the weird thing is if Megan
wanted to go and make an acting deal
right now she could probably crush it
and get a great acting deal but I don't
think that's what she's looking for
because acting is now way too much hard
work basically there there are none
they're a non-factor here actually I
mean in Hollywood nobody talks about
them at all I'm told that they just
they're just you know the whole
celebrity canvas is so much bigger wider
and hotter they're not really a factor
they're just they're just miners who
show up at celebrity events and so on so
there's nothing really going on with
their brand uh here and I think that
they've really got to figure out
obviously they have taken advice finally
and gone quiet which is exactly what
they should have done like shut up like
go away and they have gone away for the
entire summer but they've got to figure
out what archwell is you're like what's
it for you know what is it what is it
actually for they haven't raised very
much money with it to be honest I mean I
think it's 12 or 30 million dollars or
something you think by now it'll be 100
million
the problem they've got is they actually
the only currency they have so far that
has proved remotely interesting to the
public is when they're trashing their
families and I I find that pathetic and
sad and it's caused unbelievable risks
not just with his family with her family
the poor father sitting there 50 miles
away has never met his grandchildren
he's never met the person that married
his daughter despite bringing up Megan
on his own for years all of it is just
incredibly on a human family level
incredibly sad uh and I you know they
keep talking about how happy they are
over there how happy could anybody be if
you're estranged from both of your
families I mean I just don't know how
can you be happy is there vulnerability
and I agree there is a vulnerability
because they're outside the institution
but I I don't know what Adam Tina feel
about this but that's why I believe that
the rapprochemore the olive leaf the
move towards making they're never going
to be a happy family of again but some
kind of Redemptive has to come from the
King but hang on hang on he's made
efforts to do this the problem is they
don't trust Harry anymore they believe
he's going to be taping them recording
them making notes doing stuff for future
something kind and loving does it matter
if you're taped my son I am told Charles
has tried multiple times to do this but
Harry wants them to apologize to him for
the damage he's been reeking on the
royal family is young people
let's face it though I mean it is not in
Megan's interest to have her approximal
between Harry and his family that's why
I don't think it'll happen because Megan
does not want to live in England ever
again nope she feels that England was
just uh you know rejected her she
rejects it uh she finds it cold boring
nothing for her she loves her you know
the Hollywood apparently said tonight
she wants to beat yeah he apparently
said tonight in his speech at this
charity event that his wife was really
sorry she couldn't be there that's
complete nonsense she's not sorry she
can't be there she was at two Beyonce
concerts last week if she wanted to be
there she'd be there
um she doesn't want to be there for the
reasons
and then the Hope got taken away and
that's why you know what if you trash
your family in public in the way that
they've done for so long eventually any
family would go that's it drawbridge
down done and that's sadly where we are
incredible that he's here Harry and he's
not going to see his brother or his
father
everything I will say about that is this
this family has never been a
touchy-feely family I mean you know they
never rushed to family reunions except
at Christmas Easter you know this is not
a family that is all over each other
yeah at the best of times yeah and quite
obviously Harry's completely alienated
his family and it's done I I don't quite
understand why Journal you know English
coverage is constantly about and he
comes to England and he hasn't seen his
family no they're estranged no no I
agree No One's Gonna rush I totally
agree we're gonna leave it there Tina
Brown lovely to see you uh good to see
you Tessa Ed Owens after Elizabeth can
the monarchy save itself actually a
really interesting book about the future
of our monarchy here does it have a
future how long is that future I hope it
does I think it will but work to be done
by King Charles he's doing a great job
but work to be done in reshaping now the
monarchy in His image for what he wants
for us and the country uh great to see
you all thank you very much indeed well
it says next I'm very excited about this
one of the most influential young men in
American Media Charlamagne thy God which
is a great name uh I might have to adopt
some of that myself here's Morgan the
god we'll interview Charlemagne the God
after the break is it if you saw the
most powerful people in the world
politicians are queuing up to Crave his
approval will he get mine well we'll
find out next because Charlemagne the
God will be uncensored after the break
[Music]
foreign
Trump yeah look at him fail not working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks do you believe you can
win this wall this is making me cry
again I'm trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy letby will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I honestly wish I'd never met
him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
they roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I don't know you're probably going
to vote me after church
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's
the threat that you'd be worried about
yeah so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
when I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drug you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
welcome back to please organized
anything called the hip-hop Howard Stern
Charlemagne the God it's one of the most
influential voices in the American Media
right now with a smashing show and a
very influential predominantly black
audience here he is in action
what is it about music that you love so
much that would still make you want to
go on the damn radio grind because you
don't need it you're rich you're famous
you don't need to be on this radio grind
I love I love music put your hands in
there
once I'm singing This is how we're
living down here sitting on the edge
looking out without disorder if you
don't mind us you know what I had a
really strong voice like exceptionally
strong voice July it was 46 years old
and they do mention your husband a lot
and he said how is she's so black was
she married white you got more questions
but I tell you if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're familiar
Trump then you ain't black
well Charlemagne joins me now
Charlemagne it's great to have you on
uncensored thank you very much indeed
for finally uh
thank you thank you for having me how
are you I don't really fascinated by you
because we come from very different
backgrounds upbringings I was always
wanted to be a journalist I trained to
be a journalist I went to a English
journalism college and worked my way up
and I do a lot of interviews you came
from a very different background in
South Carolina nothing about that
background suggested that you would end
up being one of the most influential
interviewers in American Media how do
you think that's happened
I think that's happened because
um you know I'm I'm I always approach
things from the perspective of just a
curious fan you know I always feel like
the know-it-all knows nothing and you
know I'm not an expert at anything I'm
just the person who you know has some
experiences in life and you know my
mother was an English teacher in South
Carolina and you know one of the things
that she told me when I was younger was
to always read things that you know uh
don't necessarily pertain to you so
being that she told me that I always had
this curiosity for a little bit of
everything so I would read everything
from you know the double XL magazine to
you know every Judy Bloom book in the
library and I think just having that you
know curiosity and always approaching
things from the perspective of a curious
fan you know I think that might be that
might be intriguing to some people it's
very intriguing a whole story very
intriguing to me uh you were born
Leonard Larry McKelvey and I'm a big
Bernard Leonard I got to correct you
from I'm sorry
you'd be called Leonard over here
um but what's interesting about you is
I'm a big believer in second chances for
people God knows I've had enough of them
myself in my career
um but you in your early years you got
into a bit of trouble you were arrested
twice for possession of drugs on your
third arrest uh because you were near a
non-fatal shooting at the time uh your
father refused to pay bail money and you
went to jail and after 41 days you asked
your mother to pay for the bill and that
point your father decided to give you
another chance how when you look back on
it how pivotal was that moment of your
father deciding I'm going to give him
another another go at this and see what
happens
man that was um that was very pivotal
you know and and honestly it wasn't a it
wasn't it wasn't something that I I took
it serious as I should because you know
I kind of went back you know to to
hanging around the same crowd and you
know being involved in a lot of the same
you know type of activities but it was
very it was very pivotal for me you know
because my father used to always tell me
something he would always say man if you
don't change your lifestyle you're going
to end up in jail dead or broke sitting
under the tree and you know when you're
that age and you start to see people
around you actually go you know the the
prison for for long stint so you saw
people around you actually dying or you
saw people that you used to look up to
you know actually be broke sitting under
the tree and you know you can kind of
see yourself going down that same path
it kind of like is a wake-up call you
like yo my father is right so that for
me that was one of those you know
moments that just made me say I do have
to to change my lifestyle because I
truly believe that destiny is not a a
matter of chance it's a matter of choice
and you know I think a lot of us we just
make you know poor choices for for
whatever reason so you know I just think
you know you make you make you make
better choices you better the chances of
uh you know having having a more
successful life I completely agree now
takes it takes a healthy ego let me put
it like that to rename yourself the god
why did you do that
oh because I studied I grew up studying
the five percent teachers you know and
in the five percent teachers they teach
you that uh God is a Greek word derived
from the Arabic Words gumar azabar which
means wisdom script and Beauty in the
first letter of each word was used by
Greek students and their identification
of their you know Egyptian teachers so
that's one thing and then in the Bible
it says God created Man In His Image
according to his likeness so you know
whenever somebody literally said this to
me uh yesterday when I was doing
something unhealthy which is reading the
comments on social media and they said
your name is derived from ego and I said
no actually my name is derived from uh
five percent teachings in in scripture
very interesting and that Biden clip
that we had at the end there let's move
to the the general political scene in
America right now Biden's claim there in
that interview that if basically if
you're a black person in America you
should be voting for him
um let's just replay that again just to
remind viewers of this
you got more questions but I tell you if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or Trump and you ain't
black
now what did you make of that when he
said that what was your instinctive
reaction
my instinctive reaction was exactly what
I said in that moment like you know it's
not about Trump it's just about me you
know wanting to you know get something
for my community you know votes are
transactional you know we vote for you
um you do something for us and so that's
literally where my mind was at and and
you know even with that you know you
ain't black comment that he made you
know I think he got that from black
people that were around him at the time
and I think that was a a Granddad joke
but I I I think what he was trying to
say is simply you know if you vote for
Donald Trump as a black person you may
be voting against your own interests and
what do you think about that
what do I think about what about what
you just said about what people may have
thought by meant do you think that is
true do you think you're voting against
your own interests as a black American
if you've over Trump
yes I do because you know I feel like
you know Donald Trump is a a threat to
democracy and um you know when you talk
about a country that could be leaning
toward fascism because you have people
in a party that are leaning toward
fascism you know as a black person or
any minority I don't think you know you
would want to live under a fascist
regime and you know that's not something
that you know it doesn't matter what
your money how much money you have or
you know what your status is you know if
you're a person of color or a minority
under a fascist regime regime I don't
think that's going to fail too well for
you the problem at the moment it seems
for people who share your views about
that there are many Americans who share
uh that opinion of trump and there are
many who still support him is that Trump
is running away with the Republican
nomination race fueled it seems by all
these legal issues that he has the more
times he gets indicted we're up to
nearly 100 criminal charges now the more
popular he seems to get and part of that
is people thinking it's the
establishment trying to destroy him and
people don't like that in America even
if they don't agree necessarily with
Trump's political views they just think
he's getting put upon and victimized is
all this backfiring do you think just as
a as a reality check about the political
environment
I kind of expected this like you know I
knew that it was an easy call for him uh
to say that it's gonna it's a Witch Hunt
you know I I kind of I kind of predicted
that you know if he was listening to you
know my radio show The Breakfast Club on
my podcast the brilliant idiots I was
saying that you know uh I I could see a
lot of this working in his favor now I
don't know how it's going to work in a
general election because I think you
have a lot of independent voters I don't
know if they'll necessarily you know uh
show up for him and you know those
hypothetical swing voters who you know
voted for President Obama one year and
then came back and voted for you know
Trump another year they might have came
back and you know voted for President
Biden I don't know if they're
necessarily going to show up but the
thing I find interesting about Trump
um president Trump the most is that um
you know you you have 91 criminal
charges uh what is it for for
indictments I haven't heard him talk
about policy at all I haven't heard him
talk about you know any legislation he
wants to implement at all every time
he's getting on television it's about
The Witch Hunt and it's about the
charges against him and to me man I
would have to look at the people who are
supporting him and say well what are
y'all supporting like because because
he's not even out there campaigning I
mean the other the other side of the
coin is that Biden himself is now
looking horribly old and it's not about
his age it's just his ability to perform
to function I know you said a lot about
this yourself that you're very concerned
about this Nikki Haley wants to put term
limits now on age limits now on
politicians you're seeing it with Mitch
McConnell you're seeing it with Dianne
Feinstein you've seen Biden falling over
and stumbling and making mistakes
constantly it does seem an extraordinary
situation that America this incredible
multi-racial Multicultural uh place can
only come up at a 330 million people
with Joe Biden and Donald Trump one
already in his 80s one heading to his
80s one facing nearly 100 criminal
charges one can barely string a sentence
together how can it be this is the only
choice that might be presented to the
American people next year
man you're absolutely right peers and
that's something that you know I discuss
a lot and people around me discuss a lot
but the only thing I can tell people
right now and I I I don't belong to you
know any particular party but I will
tell you that you have one party who
still seems like you know they're
they're they're they're attempting to
preserve democracy you know no matter
how old their leadership is and you have
some another party that seems like you
know they're on the fast track the
fascism so you just have to ask yourself
do you care about democracy or not as an
American you just have to ask yourself
that simple question do you care about
democracy or not if the answer is yes
then hey man you might have to vote for
the elderly
it's an extraordinarily disparaging
Choice uh Charlemagne it's great to talk
to you thank you thank you very much and
David coming on the show I appreciate it
thank you
well it says the next a terror suspect
On The Run of escaping from ones with
prison dresses as a chef how can that
happen or are we just not surprised
because everything else in Britain is
broken we may as well include the
prisons I package here to debate there
and much more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook join me now is
my pack totally contributions lawyer all
about Adrian told to be a presenter
Richard Tyson International editor
that's a wonderfully fancy title Isabel
OSHA welcome to all of you you see
you've all missed me even if your eyes
and expressions are telling a different
story
um Richard uh our prisons join the long
list of things that simply aren't
working in this country what is going on
why does nothing work anymore why can't
we even keep dangerous terrorists in
prison it's got worse since you've been
away Pairs and I mean this is nothing
short actually of gross negligence
that's all it is I mean if you and I
said let's go and run a few prisons I'm
pretty sure the first thing we would do
is to say when Vehicles come in and out
we should check the roof inside and
underneath it is the most basic stuff
here's the thing though it cannot be
just this one individual on their own
the CCTV everywhere if you actually look
at the uh the entrance and exit of that
prison there are two secure zones that
vehicle will have gone through there has
to be in my view I mean I've actually
I've gone into some of these prisons to
interview people or whatever or to see
people and the levels of security you
have to go through is absolutely
mind-boggling to me as well that anyone
could actually in this day and age get
out of one of these things which is why
I think it was absolutely an inside job
there will have been multiple people I
am sure that's my instinct assisting
this individual and we know from the
testimony of so many prison officers and
other sources that there is a huge
amount of corruption in our prisons a
huge amount of drugs and bribery and all
sorts will have gone on to but do you
feel when you feel like I do that it is
indicative of a wider malaise in the
country about almost everything 100
everywhere I go now people say what is
wrong with this country is working we
talk about this every day don't we and
every every day you see more and more
examples whether it's a collapsing
schools rights of the NHS not working
you get on a train inevitably it's late
you ring a call center no one answers
because you can't see a doctor you can't
do this you can't do that my volume of
calls nothing works but Paula the
problem is as always it's the people
with the least amount of money and
ability to get through all this cost of
living crisis and so on who suffer the
most right absolutely and you see that
frustration spilling out onto the street
you see it in relation to you thinking
that it's okay to arrange a raid on JD
Sports or wherever it is you see um
protesters but members of the public
attacking protesters because they don't
feel that the police are acting in their
best interests and allowing them to get
on with their daily work you see it in
relation to what's happening to the
u-less cameras and attacks on YouTube
cameras because you also see it you also
see it in what's happening with the NHS
which I'm a massive fan of and I've had
good reason to be a massive fan of over
many decades with family and friends and
so on uh and particularly Great Ormond
Street where I had a cousin who was a
consultant neurologist there for the
kids for many years and Brilliant
um but in the middle of all this you
read a story the advice for staff at
Great Ormond Street Hospital
urges them to stop using gendered
language in conversation it's just the
wrong pronouns can make people feel
disrespected invalidated dismissed
triggered alienated or often all of
these things and they've stopped people
to use words like boy or girl or man or
woman and I'm sorry uh Richard I how are
they finding the time exactly right to
do this stuff but secondly where are the
rights I'm going to say this again where
are the rights of people like me who
would like to be called a man or Isabel
who I suspect would like to be called a
woman when she goes to a hospital or a
boy or a girl where are the rights of
the vast majority of people to carry on
being cool what they damn well want to
be called I just want people in the
hospitals doctors and nurses to be
focused focusing on looking after the
patients right nothing else that it's
the time and energy not just the money
the resource that's wasted
this is one's mentality that everything
has to now be inclusive even if in the
process it excludes the majority of
people from what they want and actually
Richard you know the truth is that the
doctors are nurses the healthcare
professionals actually also want what
you want there's two exhaust brings them
more than these endless never met
adultery they want to use gender-neutral
language
Paula I'm coming to you last because I
know what's going to happen you're going
to launch a spirited ludicrous defense
and you're all going to agree go on
there because you know I'm right this
and I am disappointed in you all is
actually a good news story why it's a
good news story because it's people
being respectful to people and you say
what about the rights of your UPS to be
called a man who said you weren't going
to be if I go to great on the street
they won't call me a man well I as I
understand it the guidelines are that
you will be asked how you prefer to be
referenced as you will then explain how
you Perfection you will be reference
can you imagine getting to this can you
imagine going to Ukraine right now and
saying to those people do you feel
disrespected in validated dismissed
triggered alienated all of those things
by the wrong pronoun why did you think
we've lost our our perspective on
reality of what it feels like to
actually be oppressed it's not about
being called the wrong pronoun it's
about being bombed by Russian barbarians
that is oppression this is nonsense I
think that's a poor argument because
we're not equating at the end I just did
we're not equating what the NHS are
attempting to do to make certain people
feel better
utterly ridiculous because the truth is
for you the truth is if I decide if I
decide what's a bit like the number of
letters now on the lgbtq do you know the
rest of it
something something right nobody knows
it's all complete nonsense so I
understand that there are even members
of the lgbtq who don't know themselves
uh Community you've forgot two plus who
who would who would agree with you and
so I can understand that sometimes in
terms of marketing branding getting a
message out there people get it wrong
but that but that isn't a reason it's
not a coincidence the quality of the
service the outcomes of the NHS are
declining because they're overmold
because they're wasting time there are
people in grade people in Great Ormond
Street you are having to come on know
that that's having to come up struggling
our NHS is not struggling because there
are people out there it is
to do what they've always done so
brilliantly and become world leaders in
which is take care of sick kids I don't
want them worrying or fretting about
whether somebody is available it is
anyway let me just turn to
something else which is which
is hey there's something in the rounds
online it's probably an old one I don't
know but it's fun it's a it's about the
perfect tea it's a meme about the
perfect tea somebody has come up here uh
with a a sort of grit and I think we've
got it here we can show the grid so they
reckon that uh E3 right is the perfect
example of the perfect color tea I think
that is overstewed I am more of a C4 I
think that is the perfect color and it
has to be Yorkshire gold obviously but
that is it's four it's four C no sorry
D2 D2
Isabelle
can we see it again can we see it again
you've got to see it all the time sorry
we can't take it down
[Music]
I was just gonna say A1
[Laughter]
A1 and then you say but the trouble for
that is it's racist
I think you'll find I'd probably be a C5
I'm a world expert on team making I've
actually taught Americans how to make it
and it's C4 anyway it's a good debate oh
thank you Pat good to see you I'm glad
we all reached a position of totally
disagreeing as always always more fun
that way and sense of next the vegans
are back you'll be pleased to know
offending common decency with an advert
so vile it's had to be bad the moment
behind that advert is here to explain
why yogurts are evil that's next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
wall this is making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
[Music]
juicing oil the knock-on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
you're probably going to vote me off
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air
thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's
the threat that you'd be worried about
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
when I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has been telling
the trails you don't drink never taken
drug you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
foreign
suspect Daniel Khalif after the runaway
ex-soldier is accused of spying for Iran
and as Rishi sunak takes off for the G20
India's prime minister lashes out at
Western countries for lecturing on
climate change and in a surreal Royal
running Prince William shares a kiss
with Paul gascoigne at bournemouth's
press amanji That's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
we all know Muller yogurts these creamy
treats with crunchy or fruity bits in
your corner other Delicious Brands are
available apparently all yogurts are
evil they're murderous a vegan charity
is released an ad about them that will
give you nightmares a warning you might
find this disturbing
but when I hear vegans talking about
this
sorry we've got the wrong clip there
we're going to play the right one I hope
have we got the right one sorry my
apologies
we don't have the clip but we are going
to find it anyway it's a pretty gruesome
clip of well basically makes out that
this yogurt here the Muller
we do have it we do have it here we go
new from killer yogurts the
umbilical cord flavor
produced with only the finest
ingredients
the stolen milk of grieving mothers
taste the torment in every mouthful
[Music]
blended with brutality
be complicit
[Music]
with killer yogurt
well I'm joined now by the director of
the charity Viva who made the ad Juliet
glattly well Juliet
I've got to be honest that's one of the
most disgusting things I think I've ever
had to watch it's also one of the most
disingenuous it's a yogurt for goodness
sake why are you making ads like that
about a yogurt I'm sorry I don't believe
that that's the most disgusting thing in
your editorial career that you pretty
much one of them I gotta be honest I'm
sorry it's a pantomime style it's
obviously a parody it's obviously fake
blood
um you know over three million people
saw it
um
well the point is we went into an
investigated Dairy farming and blew
apart the notion that these animals are
in idle most one one in five of the
animals and supplying people like that
were zero Grace this means they never
saw a blade of grass and I went so I
went in myself to check this out and
they're in filthy conditions the male
calves taken away and shot or knifed in
the throat because they don't produce
milk the mothers when their milk
production went down killed so there's a
lot of death in the day let me ask you
this what do you think happens in the Y
Wild
how do you think animals eat
what species are you talking well you're
very you're very concerned about the
protection of animals but if you go to
the African bush animals eat each other
all day long and the most Savage Prime
Evil way why aren't you campaigning
about that yeah what are you going to
protect animals from other animals yeah
listen my degree is already I know quite
a lot about animals and then my Tick
Tock feed all I see all day are lions
destroying gazelles come on they're not
which is a bit more gory than that
they're not it's real life they're not
Factory farmed these animals never see
sunlight they never graze a blade of
grass it's obscene I don't think even
you would agree with that well I always
my problem with vegans is this I mean I
bet you're a you probably like almonds
do
Oh no you're not gonna do the Almond
avocado with me it's asking you do you
eat this is boring it may be boring I
actually find the vegan assault on meat
eat it's boring so do you eat avocado as
an armor I'm not assaulting do you eat
them anybody do you eat them
so you do you eat avocados because the
issues that you are doing did you drink
what kind of milk would you drink you're
talking about the milk kind of milk do
you drink you talk about the soya soya
okay yeah so you talk about the murder
of bees in other interviews yes because
vegans don't care but you don't care
about the billions no calves and chicks
and piglets I understand you're a
complete hypocrite no I'm not you are
people no the Hypocrites are the vegans
who lunch away on almonds and and their
avocados and stuff they don't give a
damn about billions of bees getting
annihilated it's the bees are the little
guys and I had this conversation each
time because that's the hypocrisy I
don't care obsessed with this no because
you think it catches I am a proud and
happy meal yes when you try and make out
this yogurt is the most evil thing that
anyone has in the world I think your
Bonkers yeah we're in the six mass
extinction we're living it now you're
behaving like a news Anchorage
you're behaving like a news Ancon
Extinction you're deflecting all the
time the world is not going to end you
decide
or factory farmed you're trying to
deflect from the facts veganism protects
we're still here we are but nobody's
extended have we got you've got kids you
must care about the climate crisis I let
my kids eat meat I let them eat yogurt
and you know what I don't think it's
evil you must care about the climate
crisis and you must be aware that the
University of Oxford has specifically
stated that a vegan diet it protects the
ingredients
almonds or avocados from Spain which one
from Spain which one both I don't eat
almonds how do they get avocados how do
they get here Boat Boat really you sure
yes I am sure you sure I am absolutely
sure really and how do you think most
vegans get most of their almonds
avocados from California and how do you
think no they don't Cheetos get there
[Applause]
do you eat avocados yes
but you care about all these millions of
bees no I care about your hypocrisy
about the little guys rubbish most bees
are killed because of overuse of
pesticides most of them not true not
true it's due to the way that it's in
the policy in the politics
animals that is not so you're talking
most of the bees get killed in the
pollination process and by the way after
they get killed you vegans get all your
arms and avocados flown over on these
gas guzzling planes and my point is I
like to fly I like to eat meat I like to
eat yogurts I'm just fed up with vegans
trying to shame me for it when you're
all such Hypocrites when it comes to the
bees no you're not you're against
factory farming if you went inside the
Farms that I've been inside and the
reason that I set up Viva the state of
the animals that I've seen them in pigs
really dying in front of me if this
makes me evil you wouldn't this makes me
evil I am happy to be evil it's
disgusting
that's it from me whatever you're up to
keep it creamy
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]